so now we're hearing about some people
in some states protesting stay-at-home
Orders aimed at slowing the spread of
coronavirus in Michigan
protesters followed social distancing
guidelines by driving around the state
capital of Lansing hoping to cause a
traffic jam Grady Trimble was there
reports in Lansing now what happened
Grady well bill it's still going on this
thing started at around 11 o'clock this
morning and it shows no signs of
stopping they wanted to clog the streets
here and that's exactly what they're
doing they're sending a message to
Governor Gretchen Whitmer that they
don't agree with her stay at home order
they say it goes too far takes away
their rights and in some cases is too
arbitrary for example you can go on a
sailboat or a canoe but not on a motor
boat you can't go to a second home if
you live in the state but someone from
out of the state can drive to their
second home in Michigan and at big-box
stores you can buy groceries and
medicine but there are certain areas of
the store that have to remain closed
such as the parts of the store that sell
paint carpet and flooring as well as
garden supplies and furniture many of
the people I spoke to here say there are
some secret provisions and that the
governor did this for our own political
and I can't go between those houses you
can't buy paint you can't fight a lot
you can't play lawn fertilizer or grass
seed or what come on
I think she's doing it so she can get
national press like this and be Joe
Biden's vice presidential candidate I
don't know what I don't know what other
reasons it's just crazy
governor Whitner says she understands
people are frustrated and angry and she
also says she supports their right to
protest like this she just hopes they do
it in a way where they practice social
distancing and don't jeopardize their
health or the health of the first
responders here a lot of the people I
talked to bill say they're okay with a
stay at home order but they think it
shouldn't be one size fits all for
example there are a lot more cases in
Detroit than there are in rural parts
that's unbelievable great to keep an eye
on a thank you with loud Grady Trimble
Lansing Michigan thank you very much for
that great evil